Charlotte welcome to the iron Lords
podcast episode number 15 special Monday
edition and the Lords are in the
building actually a very special guest
my man of the weapon world podcast
killing that crushing difficulty right
now and uncharted for the Nace's my man
Louis moves in the building how we doing
Louis Malle what's everybody I am doing
swell um you know feeling good trying to
try to win this rack right now but um
well the thing you guys for having me I
think is my second appearance on the
iron Lords podcast yes sir but yeah I'm
glad to be here
nice oh it's moves in the building
always family of course we got the usual
suspects at the round table Monday
edition my brother from another mother
the non-ag rogamus which gang in it
lately my me Lord addict was going on
genetic nothing much man just saw
children uh telling them in Lord smooth
comment section you know making sure
that people don't come at him too hard
in history I'm telling you Matt I must
have timed out 15 people
it's moderated duties was real the
lottery to do you there no doubt though
and of course we have tech in with a man
that's board loominatee and more
cognitive incognito himself Louis are
you in the building was going on what's
up what's going on what's going on doing
good little under the weather last week
but definitely feeling much better this
week looking forward the NBA playgrounds
tomorrow get a little retro NBA Jam
going on my switch so messed up I put it
for the $20 - I'm ready yeah bucks
and of course we got my me the premium
experience the excess gamer all of it
what's good Lord King how we doing today
how we going fantastic yesterday I
pull apart for the switch and we win
Tetris it is a fabulous blend of both
games and then you can do so much stuff
we have so many options inside of it it
is probably one of the best party games
that I got in my house right now no
doubt though yeah heard a lot of good
things about it I gotta get my hands I
said they have a free demo out right now
too of that I saw one of the cabmen
games so I gotta get my hands on that to
put on his lower cut needling a building
fresh off the operating table for y'all
showing that dedication that looks good
let's get yesterday but uh Lord is back
and we're ready to get this thing
rocking on real quick as far as what
I've been playing or Merrill cards been
late I mean one thing I had to say or
the switch is amazing in an emergency
room
oh maybe the switch save me it made that
time flush I just got that and I'm you'd
be proud of me Lord sovereign I actually
started the UM the my first divine beast
actually started a quest line for the
first time oh and you had a lot of time
on my hands so yeah red I actually
started that giant and um I think it's
what is his sauce run a water wonder
what elephant thing oh yes I did that
once I very happy doing that going but
um yeah man watch whatever so the Lords
and everybody been playing start with a
lost move which we've been playing uh
lost a son Charlie
I know you've been rockin that that's
all he's really good quiet relaxing this
before I had started that I was playing
um damn I'm playing Mario Kart 8 now
with you guys he's there's another game
I started do Bioshock eminent and I was
playing on that and I'm trying to try to
jump into a dark Sider since I've never
played any of them they just really
follow me master so good looks at you
that's a good look for you right there
thanks nice now Lord addict my man
what's been going on I know we got Xbox
down but what else was we going on for
you
um I was playing Darksiders one to my
xbox one down but I'm playing the switch
right now don't know that boy is a beast
on that Mario I don't like him and them
races he doing
too strong Windham crowns he needs to go
toe to toe with Lord cobot suit because
Kai bots yeah can't wait he's got a good
little party gonna be a lot of extra I
get that going
yes sweet hello sorry I'm a beast you
know you are there we go like this one
on one up at today no words teaching
what you play um I actually started to
get back into our horizon zero dawn a
little bit you know after the zelda
craziness which I'm again I haven't done
much of anything in Zelda I'm leaving
that sorta for the e3 true but horizon
zero dawn and Marik are definitely uh no
doubt he has pretty bad three miles
Bennett switch game switch game and Lord
King was been on a rotation well I was
trying to jump in assassin's creed's
after I saw the garbage movie that
popped out on my arm but how do we get
that and then I had to wash the taste
out of my mouth with it actually a good
game cuz it's a horrible movie um but um
you know Swift stuff everything switched
right now I'm about everything switch
I'm not even sitting a lot of you The
Price is Right
the games are smooth 60 frames per
second 1080p these games is really on
point is like well design games and I'm
loving it
down Colvin's everybody's been rocking
have some fun so we're gonna get right
into the show right now and she'll start
off with bro Lord attitude because um a
lot of room is in these streets about
PlayStation 5 and you know when this
thing could drop and what you got enough
to tell to the roundtable about this uh
these rumors not attic all right oh you
know typically we do podcasts on Sundays
look you know we had it we got delayed
so we're a little
a bit a little bit what's where I'm
looking for we're late behind we're late
on this but attaching them you know uh
someone that the person who predicted
the the slim and the probe has another
prediction I don't know what the name of
this individual is it's it's some kind
of animal is I don't know I didn't
really look into it because the moment I
heard the topic in the title I was I
just shut the whole thing down I was
like this not happening but he predicts
that the ps5 is going to come out in
2018 and part of the issue that I'm
having with this is people are like oh
he's credible he he's predicted some so
you mean to tell me he predicted that
three years later they were gonna make a
slim yeah cuz it's not like that's never
happened before
how long was the neo rumor before it
actually was a fully announced as a pro
it would have took too many people to
realize when that was coming out hey hey
um what is what are the Lord's thing
let's uh get this free discussion as far
as it was to jump in about I believe the
analyst his name uh Wesley Mach Sachi or
whatever and I'm not she Sue's me Daniel
mind also there's a couple other guys
made some comments in reference to him
so do you guys think this is legit what
are the Lord's feeling on possible ps5
and 2018 I'll take that um no I know
this happening you didn't happen it for
a simple fact the reason why it's
happening and you can sit there sale
damn it happened um it's because this
Scorpio is going to be so powerful and
they took away the power plate it you
know we are the most powerful system
they'll be trying to run that we have
the game stuff until the fact that
Microsoft all the third-party games run
better on Scorpio alright so then
they're gonna start scrambling because
they're going to start looking to grab
up that market share because switch is
gonna be in today market year so this is
where the screw-up happens instead of
holding fast and stay in the course
they're gonna greedy exit
32x to jump off and they're gonna throw
that out there and anybody that
purchased the pro is probably gonna
opening windows and throw it out the
window
if that happens because I'm really
pissed off right now with the prom not
even sit here like at a stay pack with
my regular place that he should there's
nothing going on with this Pro that
indicates that I needed it at all all
right so they lied they said it was
gonna do this and it does absolutely
nothing and I'm pretty sure anybody got
a pro you got to jump in and tell me if
you if you're Pro does something
different then I reckon PlayStation let
me know because I see them so happy
matches so bad this ashes work for a
regular PlayStation 2 so look a little
insane again you get no improvement you
never know fathers coming even Dez there
was worth the upgrade and I get I don't
know I completely understand that for me
it would bother me to know that horizon
zero dawn looks a little bit better on
on the pro and I don't have it in my
house I know what I know would bother me
so I mean again I'm not happy what
they've done so far but at the same time
when I do play something I'm confident
in knowing that it's the best version
whatever that means
whatever that means cuz they did not
they're not really applying uh what
power the system has it's not really
applying it to every single game coming
down the pipeline
it's very hit-or-miss and that's that's
kind of ridiculous um so yeah you know
they they they need to do something
about that so I told you agree with lore
King never regard that loss who looks
like you you different so I want to get
your perspective you think about this
ps5 thing um yeah I think it's bogus and
they keep referring to this um for
predict he didn't predict freaking de
mio or to slim he was he was just the
first major person with a name to start
and talking about the rumors just like
all of us little youtubers were when
when the rumors is should start to come
out I had the damn white papers for Neil
for the
longus now it's dropping hit everyone
twitter because i want to give my [ __ ]
taken down like they took down my
playstation slim video just for having
an image um so that's so people are in
the thing is he his prediction isn't new
they're just rearing up his article and
that's like which is old his prediction
is own they're just doing this because
of because of the scorpio
there's no playstation 5:18 none of me i
don't know when a pleasure to 5 is
coming it would be stupid for them to
drop plenty 5 because they haven't even
supported the playstation 4 pro yet and
when i say they haven't supportive
places for a pro we're looking at the
pro and there's probably only a handful
of games that actually sees it and like
a legit approvement like oh that's the
pro version you know um and and that's
that's where is like yo this is like
this right here this pro right here is a
ripoff they haven't done anything so
there's there's nothing on the
playstation 4 that's really taking full
advantage of what the pro is supposed to
do and um the playstation 4 itself has
been selling like hotcakes they're a
market leader they got all their games
out and they got a whole ton of games
that they announced that are due to
release of 2018 and 2019 where he's
gonna be playstation 5 games now like i
don't see i just don't see it happening
and if it does i don't know if that
bodes well for them i don't think
they're not gonna turn out as a
depletion for you know i mean i mean i
don't know who what who ever hurt more
does it hurt by yourself or does it what
I heard Sony I say shouldn't hurt Sony
in the fact that they made more than
what they were expected to make with the
PlayStation 4 so I guess a but I might
but what are they really doing how would
this affect is this gonna because no a
playstation they're not really popular
on backwards-compatible I feel like if
they drop ride live that [ __ ] needs to
be a hundred and ten percent
backwards computable I think I think it
may not be 2018 but they definitely
mentioning something this year whether
it be a what if whether B III or whether
it's at PSX they're saying something
they they're not gonna let Microsoft run
away with that now
not gonna let nintendo run away without
a narrative even know about that name
solo song let me ask you this you are
convinced that to steal the Thunder like
Layton he just announced it almost
similar like what like what Scorpio was
announced last e3 from Microsoft you
could you're convinced that they would
they would do that even though they're
the market leader is again they're in a
dominant position this has been the mo
well I mean wedding yeah when they when
they have again did it they did it in
the past few weeks means when they're
announcing games that are four or five
years out but they win that mindshare at
e3 and everybody's like oh we doesn't
mean anything yes it does because the
entire gaming world is watching III that
dictate that dictates the tone for the
rest of the year what people are excited
about what the night exciting I think
that exceed a reveal of Scorpio is crazy
stuff really two hours they have a whole
day for is a couple hours it's delayed
to Tuesday they're gonna drop it every
rock in the morning with the idea of
PlayStation five right now right is that
what we still don't have all the
information on Scorpio right and if
Scorpio is gonna do what I think is
going to do the PlayStation 5 we have to
more than Eclipse it and I don't think
they would be there in the position
ready to make an affordable console that
will be able to outdo it so they're not
dropping a console at $500 yeah it can't
cuz it would it would have to outdo
Scorpio if even if it's like on par with
Scorpio that's a problem because Scorpio
technically is just a mid-grade Xbox one
yeah right
so it has to like it has a damn near be
an 8k console for K minimum que él
encontró not be next year's oh by
dropping next year they they could
feasibly you know they can they can take
over the narrative by saying oh we have
rise in in our in our system and it's
going to be more cost-effective for them
a year
from now than it did would be right now
but actually actually self that's what
could rise in what would rise in and the
prestige of five really do though what
would it bode
I mean it would it would have to heal
for the first the first couple years
there's no they're gonna they're gonna
downplay everything to the ps4 anyway so
yeah well ake a checkerboard like this
fork a chicken or crap we got it okay
it's interesting I think you know
listening to it obviously you know this
guy it's funny his name sorry I was for
its Damien song yes is the airlift song
hey he's our guy and he's the one that's
pretty much saying that you know my
heart so-called predictions you know
it's been accurate you know a one hand I
see with what the Lord is saying I see
what you're saying on some hands as far
as taking it on the back from III you
know I've seen Microsoft has a lot of
the power narrative coming in a lot of
momentum would have an ESCO up your drop
so I can understand what you saying far
like stealing a thunder but
realistically I just can't see it
from a development standpoint because I
mean how long these systems take to
develop me what was Phil talking about
like at least two years and you know
when they were talking about Scorpio and
then they waited an additional year
because you know they didn't feel
resources tech wise they were ready to
do the full 4k jump so in this case you
know you got Sony that just recently
dropped the the neo right the ps4 pro
and they have touted this to their base
as the next generation sister I mean you
know they're mid generation refresh so
to speak but they haven't they haven't
really like they haven't they haven't
done what Microsoft's done with it it's
maybe very low-key they it's almost like
they don't care if they sell that one
but they did mention it as like the
premium console they this is the the
hardcore this is like the next level so
the one they want to compete with pcs
right so how do you how do you tell your
I mean not saying that they what it's
impossible for them to do it because if
they do it I agree Lord King it's a
major colossal mistake in my you're the
leader for you to even think about
coming out with a console right now to
meet you just anger your base
you now have made try to go from 60
million of zero like then then but
another point Louis moves is making that
I totally agree with I don't know about
you guys but I don't have confidence in
Sony's backward compatibility they've
still yet to show that they can even do
that with ps3 titles right they're still
offering the streaming service and all
the love stuff so more than like if it
was true that it was to drop it's not
going to be backward compatible at least
I would think because they haven't
proven that they can do that so if
that's the case and even if it is
powerful now you've cut off the base and
say you have to get peanuts five only
titles so to speak to me that's a major
misstep and I just won with think so I'm
the bigger this mistake my thinking is
that they they don't want to lose that
narrative for I mean they system came
out October 2016 you understand I'm
standing in that narrative for three
years like three years be deceptive but
by also you gotta look at this to
historically with the system generations
the most powerful system historically
has not always won the generation I mean
so the way I look at it is yet do we
know the scorpio titles are gonna be
better right we know they're gonna come
out you know they digital front you know
cuz digital family everyone the room is
now that they're in bed with mike so so
you know do you know did your foundry
comparisons gonna happen they gotta have
a pro version pc to screw up your
version they can go and you know if that
go all into detail of how you know which
one is better at the end of the day if
they got more install base and they're
selling more copies and Scorpios is
better okay yeah but so what and let's
be honest Sony still has a lot of the
marketing deals right so in the mind
shares mine again Sony's still the place
to go so if they get caught up with an
ego like this to say we gotta take it
back on a power narrative whoa I think
it's a colossal mistake hey uh I still
really think it dictates what Microsoft
does that Sunday I really think
what the press conference does on Sunday
and remember Monday is our hands on
let's get it let's get it poppin and I
really think Sony is basing everything
off of the reception of the Scorpio and
what is view at that moment and to
strike fear in the hearts of men they is
just little to take something very small
and once they get a hold of it they will
switch this stuff up quick virus they'll
tell you they've done it before I'm with
you a narrative I'm just not with you
guys as far as one development time
actually have a system ready back coming
2018 next year I think that I've done
from developers I mean from console
developers before you've noticed we've
seen dumb stuff from market leaders a
lot and then when they actually be doing
is their turn to myself you know and
that's that is the funny part is like
you know people are are on Sony they're
there with Saudi and they don't rip you
know when is the last time the victor
from the previous gen did not really
mess up the next year generally that's
how it works I mean I hear what you say
it would be it would be interesting if
they fell into that trap
I me personally I don't feel they need
to I don't feel it it has to but yeah
yeah I mean they get Sony that the movie
in a forced a hand to do something with
the same Microsoft is gonna be the
beneficiary of the colossal collapse I
honestly never know it's gonna be a
beneficiary of all the stupidity that
happens next
mmm-hmm which could transition into that
our next step but I want to get Lord go
back a little bit more on this as it was
his then he brought to the table you
were you at you convinced not a chance
what if so when do you think Lord addict
that it could drop 2001 P 19 2020 it
gets announced the nineteen comes out in
twenty
yeah I am here 8:22 isn't 19 or 20 the
25th anniversary of places years 20
years yeah okay uh look a kid did they
not uh didn't they have a you an
interview with uh with Sony Pro
president didn't you yeah your she was a
he's it it yet he said if he didn't say
he didn't even act like they're even
working on it at the moment like he
didn't like you know I get that you know
that's a PR thing but I feel like it
would be okay to say that you know we
are in process of research and
development I can't go into much on it
but we are in the process and that was
what last year kid yeah yeah yeah this
be interesting I mean I would it was
something about the pro yeah when they
were talking about the pro they were
asking pretty much how would that affect
like you know a PlayStation 5 and I feel
like maybe it would be possible you know
2018-2019 to get the next generation of
consoles but these mid generation
consoles happen and that's the
guaranteed thing I'm saying two thousand
twenty two thousand light earliest
because what's the point of dropping
these mid gen consoles when you're just
going to recycle in two years like it
makes no dad would be engine geysers at
least good for afford three to four
years for yeah now let me let me ask
Louis is uh you guys with me Lord let's
move not attic let me let me ask you
this question what based on what law
sovereign king is one thing that kind of
strikes me what if this Corp your reveal
is so crazy it's so bonkers the games
are so light years ahead of what ps4 is
doing you know what's gonna happen is
what I think is shown it Sony is play on
a bus right the mill King and look let's
say that you know it comes out you know
everyone's like oh it's so strong it's
so strong you know what you know Sony's
gonna do at that time they're gonna
double down on third parties cuz they
got the higher in solving it doesn't
matter what about what about that price
trap
you're not that is a counter they can do
that but thank you that anyway I don't
the price you're out what matter
depending on how much I think they might
bundle a game with the probe I don't
think they'll do a price
hmm I think that anything under par to
grovel cross there will be a price drop
on the ps4 but I don't think they're
going to do it on the pro cuz the ps4
they do a price drop you know it's it's
odor tech that's been remodeled so they
could still make money off of it but I
don't think that can make any money if
the pros is drop that but in Rose Bowl
that closed remodeled where would
somebody win here and put a jumper cable
inside put it the new processes this
obsession did nothing but connected wire
didn't agree Lord sir knee he's dead
jumper King wait did you did you talk
about that snake oil salesmen and [ __ ] I
had to say to get a little kick-started
I know I knew what he did when he when
he marketed the de Pro I know what he
did he said you guys if we take this
wire from the back and we put up in the
front way you get a better check the
board 4k except what I'll be saying we
could charge them an extra 150 dollars
it's a hell yeah but snake oil at his
fine his brothers wasn't there certain
games that was running better on the ps4
them yeah yes yes to the same issues
I think Wow Last Guardian um it's yeah
was it was it was a handful of games
that was just that that's embedded
that can happen that can't happen and
again what I'm noticing another reason
why I lost our me at this conversation
isn't why I've been waiting on holding
off on is because you know a lot of the
games were not 4k HDR they have HDR
enabled and then it seems to be like a
trade-off if you want the framerate the
rest goes down I mean if you want the
res you know the frame rate so I when I
saw those digital foundry Final Fantasy
videos and a couple other ones you know
it's kind of disappointing someone yeah
and then obviously with Scorpio
you know looming and an obviously switch
here now it was just
you know I just fell on the back burner
for me personally but I hate what a
witch guys are saying but it's gonna be
interesting to see what happens at e3 I
think if you guys were to put a
percentage on it coming out in 2018 what
would your percentage be mmm
um I'll jump first I'm gonna say I'm
gonna say 30% I still don't see them
doing it I really don't I would be
shocked I don't see a do it I'm funny
because I feel like there's is an 80%
chance Sony's dumb 30% is for the
mistake for them to depress the button
on on something guns gone impatiens sake
like turns away I'm going 5% and 5% is
them that's just me thinking they all
deal at the editor conference they go
and give a little PlayStation 5 logo and
it says 2019 oh my god that they said
something that's that's all gaming right
like it okay okay
there is a chance that they would do
this because it's just like last year
it's just like Microsoft with this
generation when you out on top you feel
like your fans will follow you no matter
what you do sure you get guessed you can
get yes literally Microsoft fell victim
today but I feels like I do feel like
what happened in the ps3 era
I don't think so DS gonna try like
random acts of stuff like that exactly
one would think what they aren't with
Playstation being an only successful
business right at the far edge of the
company is old one would think they
wouldn't jeopardize themselves
I believe Nadine Clarissa is
ridiculously large and I honestly
believe once that hubris is challenged
with the Scorpio that they will have a
heartfelt moment they would think the
Board of Directors will look over and
say well we can't lose our only cash cow
we must control this they're gonna nail
it
they should've read out a PlayStation 5
they're going to say and next year we're
bringing out the PlayStation Plus Pro oh
my no you know what you know what they
might bring out that little handheld
switch thing that they were talking
about that might be two five after the
tremendous success of the Vita
we get that we visit but if it's a folk
full-fledged console like the switch and
they can just copy because you know
they're the masters of copying what's
hot and if they can grab a fake little
switch with more power a larger screen
because you know they feel more power
and a larger screen equals up results if
they mimic what the switch is doing I
can honestly see them try and at that if
not a full-fledged I guess five I can
see them trying to hand on that on some
level only for the simple fact that and
I don't want to bleed too much into the
next topic is that you know the switch
is dominating ps4 in Japan like that's a
big deal for brick then yeah as far as
like you know over there mobile gaming
is really huge you know smaller problems
I guess in the culture is just a
different you know mindset so console
generally not doing how to use you know
moving out Easter move so yeah I mean to
see to see switch doing what they doing
it would be interesting to see the next
move Sony doesn't make when they do make
it and um you know it'll be interesting
like you guys said if the Lord save
their they get influenced but Scorpio
height range we just see what um Louis
it on gonna move us up some real quickly
and I think it soft sovereign percent
percentage I think it's like I feel like
all right the or King I feel like the
only way that they do really make this
reach with this PlayStation 5 is that
they start dramatically every month
losing sales like you know if they lose
that power perception and then like for
the like five or six months straight
they lose the mark they lose you SOS and
then they start losing UK says they have
to see the money leaving before they
reach valid that I would agree on some
level town yeah and now will lead into
my whole topic from last week that the
Scorpio is launching in August to
precipitate that whole small drought and
getting that money out of that pocket
oh wait to the end of the year there's
no pill has momentum that I can't agree
with that I can't I can't agree with
that would affect change but loss are
but I can get your percentages on
chances of it happening
twenty-four inches out there 40% for
okay cool we will wait and see so on
that note we're gonna move on to the
next topic and we're gonna make it a
little switch gang situation you got the
Nintendo switch out here moving a lot of
units so I want to bring this to the
Lords right now basically Nintendo had a
recent quarterly earnings call and the
company was talking about how you know
obviously they sold the 2.7 in the first
month and what I thought was interesting
when I went to bring to the roundtable
is that Nintendo actually made a
prediction and they said they expected
to sell 10 million switches in the
fiscal year so based on that data that
means they're able to sell 10 million in
the fiscal year they end March 2018 it
would surpass the lifetime sales the Wii
U in one year so I'm bringing this to
the Lords based on success what we've
seen obviously we know sell there was a
success and an issue you know my first
two months whatever Japan is doing well
you know we got Mario Kart 8 out on the
streets doing tremendous right now
tremendous do we think the grandpa
Nintendo is buggin out here success do
we think they could actually hit set
number you'll floor is yours anybody can
grab it absolutely go install Nintendo's
and then goes back man like to be honest
a they took a gamble on on on creating
this niche system and it worked and you
know people been gravitated to it people
so for people who have been shied away
from from portable gaming finally have
their portable machine a machine that
has the power of a console in the palm
of their hand you know I know it sounds
like a beggar like Oh like a marketing
act like a advertisement but it's the
truth and you know it gives it gives the
core gamer the best of both worlds and
they've delivered on it so far so for me
all they have to keep doing is continue
delivering the cool Indies on a weekly
give me a big Nintendo release every
month month and a half to two months on
give me some great surprises for the
rest of the year at e3 um give me
Virtual Console for multiple who please
Oh multiple old Nintendo systems Virtual
Console for everything up to GameCube or
up to and including week if you can
possibly do it um
and then just basically and then at the
when it when it comes to the holiday you
have to treat the holiday like a second
launch window like you you need to move
that Mario you need to move Selda again
and if you do that and if you've created
and if your internet and your just the
service that you're touting is is decent
and if people don't feel they're being
robbed I think they're absolutely gonna
blow those numbers away I think here's a
question for you guys I know this I
don't you know it's a new law it's a new
systems aren't nothing would do this but
you know Mario's coming out in the
holiday do you think they would bundle
it was elder to push for a Mario cell to
oh why that it got me so badly who have
you tested no we all know I think they
would do that I would have to rethink my
grandpa Nintendo thinking if they would
consider doing that okay yeah if I were
to put this on a percentage I'd say
there's a good seven percent chance that
they just clear house on holiday but if
they bundle with that Zelda is a hundred
percent chance but yeah that's gonna
move I mean that they attach if that was
a happen I mean let's let the numbers
came out wasn't the attach rate of Zelda
even more I mean cell the outsole the
actual consoles you know with more than
one hundred percent the attack yeah it
was ridiculous like 102 percent like it
was more Zelda's soul than actual
console and I guess from the demand and
people just want classic yes you know
whatever it may be so I mean yeah if
they did that oh I can see there being a
Zelda bundle a Mario bundle a Mario Kart
bundle um I don't see them putting them
together because they know Mario moves
on its own no I was just saying that
they bundle risotto and then they expect
that you know drop the bundle of like
you know the month that Mario comes out
you know the
mario odyssey they dropped that zelda
bundle people will pick up the soda
bottle because it comes to zelda and
they go pick up mario right next to it
and you talking about a zelda bundle for
three for the flattery no i won't it
would be nintendo probably won't do flat
three I feel like that would be the best
scenario for a flat three but Nintendo
won't do fly three if it if it's a
little over three I can I can really see
it because if you can still buy as
elderness if you're gonna sell it to me
for for 360 it's the same as buying them
separately like I don't see that I don't
really see the benefit in that but if
you give me a discount on it in the
bundle yeah cuz absolutely then you get
down you're like wait you know you know
how they really do it they pull that
shady stuff they drop a special
collector's edition of Zelda that's
custard that that look that that's
designed after zone see how quick people
will pick up another switch to have a
custom Zelda one and and and all the DLC
together is gonna be one package like
the master Edition or something like
that yeah I can see that possible it's
possible or smooth what do you think
about a Nintendo in these goals these
smooth just want to achievements that's
all he cares about
yeah no less we wasn't serious what
about 10 million possibly being sold and
all these uh proclamations what do you
think about all this
most most quiet right now he's he's in a
lot of lucky I believe I believe that a
ten million is possible they probably do
four to ten million to be honest with
you um it just has to be how many they
can produce how many they can be deuces
how many Dinkins nacelle simple as that
I got people that's asking me on
facebook that's adds to me on Instagram
this X on Twitter
yo arm have come across it because I
come across you know games phones and
stuff and I said no not once apply it
now one dude that I know say yo I have
an extra switch I have a couple of
switches not one and they've told me
that is the hardest thing to get right
now
right
and and when they get to the stores when
they get into anyone's hands they're
gone so your time not days is Howard's
I'm hearing I was sold man that's that's
a foregone conclusion but the thing is
what I want to know is how they're going
to keep stagnating the release of big
titles because blank Lord sovereign said
he wants these Indies to drop every week
I'm not in the store buying Indies so
that does not appeal to me at all
and then Virtual Console that's for you
I'm not in the store looking for Virtual
Console that's so don't even hit me with
that hit me with these games so my next
game that I'm looking forward to is it's
a couple of RPGs this summer that looks
really good on them and it drops with
them first so okay so I got the
exclusive with you guys and then I got
the merio that's coming up how you going
to close out the year and all we're
going to get a reveal at e3 with Metroid
that's what anybody's talking about like
that reveal for Metroid so if next
Rockets reveal next year they know
they're gonna sell Metroid get ravit
whoa yeah that would be huge
I think kid smooths back I'm back yeah
little small we just want to get you on
that a 10-million Proclamation and
intelligent making at that fiscal
earnings call do you think they can hit
that number
is it realistic based on even with the
early momentum what's your feeling on on
there um I think it's realistic if you
think about it we're not that really
only 10 years removed from the launch of
the Wii which you know did very well
the switch is is gone is the switch is a
it was a risky console but I think they
treated it well I don't like how they
did their you know the create demand
thing I think that we had a long
discussion about that thing in Xbox Live
I think during a lunch week um but um I
think it's possible and because they
exceeded their expectations
um and the games
are and I know they're just Wii U ports
but they're like when they drop them I
mean they're they're selling like crazy
you look at Zelda you look at Mario Kart
um Mario Kart did like what 700,000 and
a day yeah it's um I think the 10
million is possible I think now I don't
think majority of that is going to come
from like North America I think the
majority of that's going to be you know
Japan and maybe not but um I think they
can do it my only I said my only thing I
want I want Nintendo to feel like they
need to bring the switch to current
times like I'm hosting you would like to
switch to that be grandfather while you
work like I don't want like to switch it
if they're successful if they do that 10
million that means the stuff that we
want
ain't gonna happen mm so can't be the
stuff that you want will hurt what's
going on now that 1080p 60 miles per
second nah maybe my nose first
I don't I do I want to switch hey think
of being 700 P if it wanted to
I cuz it like the thing is I imagine my
switch right and I sometimes I pretend
like dang if this was an Xbox or
Playstation I won't let it go love it
but it's competitive what it does as a
handheld I like it as a console I like
it I don't like the lacking of a hat it
doesn't have anything the other
platforms have as far as social
interacting in leaderboards achievements
in the online universe is not their
innate drive a man insane and I think
that me that you have right there hurts
their user interface and bogs down the
games right now and they try to work out
the kinks I'm not really looking for
these guys to do all those things from
the jump knowing all the problems that
Xbox one had with their user interface
at the beginning the same thing with the
PlayStation forward in the beginning
they had missing apps there's certain
stuff wasn't running in 1080p it was a
lot of
problems with them force-feeding that
stuff into the user interface and it had
to go through constant revisions
constant updates constant downtime for
them to fix these kinks because like
lordotic said in the last podcast the
Xbox one user interface is not the same
interface that we got we got our system
when it launched that's really different
but it is that here's the thing with
that is that um the stuff that I'm
talking about has been a standard in
gaming for about over 10 years now and
that's that's where the problems like
it's like I I understand what the we and
I kind of didn't really give it with the
Wii U but I was like to switch come on
it's going to have you but the switch
barely has a UI yeah but you're asking a
marathon wanted to become a sprint to
overnight he's learning bro give him his
legs but be looking it's gonna come
looking I'm saying that you feel that
Nintendo doesn't I mean okay you saying
it's gonna come but do you see are you
saying you feel that you it doesn't need
it yeah that's what I don't seven no you
know I I believe it needs it right but I
don't want it in the fact that it's
broken you know I don't want to just dip
right take your time do your thing
you're winning right now we're how you
doing it don't stumble don't trip over
yourself because everybody's looking at
you and waiting for you to fall on your
face so if you release an app or Netflix
accident like oh my god Netflix only
place at 43 oh my god could you believe
it it was even out I was like that I
filled you saying looking but I will say
this to law schools point like just even
just now like before the podcast we lost
move not attic we got a game of Mario
Kart oh right and we have an opal but
we're doing this on Xbox one party check
that problem like why you don't think
you can get get like know what they
should do they should just bundle an
Xbox
they should just buy to a three-month
Xbox Live card of every three keywords
like Eddie Eddie
addict hold on hold on I have to go a
little cut
right now hey the hook do you remember
before the switch launched and I'm
telling you I'm like yo they have a app
that you can play that you can talk to
people to your cell phone it was like
there's no way because they have a
headstand and the head check is there
I'm purchase I said don't if you put
that headset it's a waste of cash
because I got lost with it you say no
Reggie fils-aime said because you don't
have that do they have that it is a
function of the system they have the
output they have the technical
specification to do it
they are sorry you don't want to know
what is your name grandpa ed for sub app
I'm assuming so will secret man but they
just not doing it
so they deceive me your trouble jargon
it is not your phone I do okay that's
all I want to get cross this is the one
I do want to say that I feel like the
right now the necessities that X that
that Nintendo desperately needs before
they start charging for this service is
they need a party system and I really
really really think that some kind of
achievement trophy system in the switch
would help the clock gentlemen if grab I
could do that loss movies on that switch
all data is ready so don't complain is
free but here's the thing no visiting
okay my back to the policies like do
feel cool on this point because like
Mario Kart is so great right is so much
higher yeah and it's like could you
imagine if it a head party checkmark
just ahead [ __ ] Road
going down and choppin alright okay is
it now we know dignity is its capable
even the Vita proved that they can do it
the Vita had parks which is a less
powerful system had Artie chat group
chat achievements all that so when they
do to me is just give me first let's
just start off with messaging can we can
I send more King a message to be like
when I first got this link I'm sitting
there playing Zelda I'm like you I'm all
hike icy Cognito 's name pump down there
I sell cool and for some reason I
expected you know modern technology to
click this little bubble icon is is
profile pops up I click it nothing I'm
like okay maybe it miss click I click it
I was like oh yeah that's right I'm on a
switch yeah yeah it's just a stalker
live is this let's see what you did
yesterday
you know they they're trying to do this
with no missteps guys I'm sorry no see I
speedy what everybody wants and I want
the same things too but I'm being so
realistic with these guys like
ultimately realistic I think we get that
for Christmas I think they say hey on
Christmas Day yeah I do not like he's
got a point I feel like that they know
they're gonna charge for the service and
I don't think they're gonna come at us
with like a really horrible service
because they know people I don't know
but you know grandpa Nintendo might
legitly think people would pay $25 for
an app on your phone to call party and
be like and every time someone has any
kind of speculation any kind of
criticism
they're like copyright copyright
copyright your windows mine you guys
like I don't care cuz I got the money
you don't yeah let's see because it's
like again I get it week right now I
feel looking same idea riding the way
they're making hand-over-fist it's it's
moving it's more than all my phone
that's I hear it and it's gotta be right
when it when they drop it it's gotta be
right just you know obviously what law
school was saying and you know modern
times grandpa come on like you know
you're almost there like just throw coz
up to be honest
like Mario Kart of you guys have played
in online the experience itself is
pretty smooth at least experience I have
like it's been the lobby's been set up
and great you move format great I wasn't
experiencing any lag or anything of that
nature and I do know it's peer-to-peer
you know is that dedicated service
obviously if someone does have a bad
connection I could affect things but you
know for the most part if you have a
stable connection in your playing Mario
Konya playing these games
it is very impressed I was actually
impressed with Nintendo that they were
able to pull that off and like I said we
just get a couple of races in afforded
full ILP and we it was it was bobbin I
thought I do full play a split screen in
the house and it's amazing I mean I
could and I compared it to the Wii U all
right because remember I still have my
Wii U and I still have the Mario Kart so
I compared to the Wii you'll remember
the Wii U's not running as fast as this
and the resolution is not safe and it
has hiccups when you're playing for
player this has no hiccups and it's 60
and it's morally good looks nice man it
does every you can actually record
needle I just got it today and I'm
sitting there playing I'm like yo like
the game feels like it's 3d cuz it's so
itchy shun whatever board the f0 boards
have a particular pop to them I'm just
like this it looks so amazing but I do
want a room let's do a rainbow road yeah
we want to say something for move on I
feel like that out of everything
Nintendo needs you know I you know
people speculate say they need third
party they do need third party but they
need social modern social aspects way
more than third party because think
about Xbox and Playstation if you didn't
have that social aspect of the Xbox in
place they should third party games yes
yeah huge communities youjin but you
don't have the IPS Nintendo have this is
what they did rocking with the eye peas
only right now this is what you gotta
understand
like they're doing this o with no social
interaction just the IP and and for all
intents that is right because all
intensive purposes I mean as great as
Mario Kart 8 deluxe is it's a remake of
you gay right let's just deal with it
for this to have this much success is
really mind-boggling to me well ask us
before you on with the Lords I just
wanted like with the Wii U with ten
million it would pass the Wii U in a
year lifetime how do we feel welcome
this bad marketing it was just bad
marketing it's you know it was a mixture
between marketing is mixture between
let's be row here the Nintendo Nintendo
like a year into the Wii U was like this
is a failure and they stopped supporting
it like for the last like two or three
years of that we use lifespan every
direct every direct uh you know they're
they're bitter idiot video directly I
think that's what they call I don't know
don't ever get something like every III
of those it was all about the 3ds
they kept building up this platform they
did moves like you know with the the
Super Smash Brothers I realized that you
know the 3ds has a fan base they wanted
to cooperate some of that install base
but like don't put the the platform that
struggling out after the platform that's
doing good it's like they should have
dropped the the Wii U version and then
like three or four months later they
should have announced and dropped the
this that the 3ds version because you
know a lot of the people that's going to
willing to go out and pick up a Wii U
they have a 3ds so if you literally give
them the option to not pick up a Wii U
and keep their 3ds and play Super Smash
Brothers because that's one of their
biggest titles you know a lot of people
pick up consoles for Super Smash
Brothers
it didn't happen I know a lot of people
they didn't buy we because they had a
handheld hey Joe think when you look up
another thing would date with the Wii U
is it their unwillingness to drop the
price they never really drop the price
of I got it on that one scene yes
it's probably the only same price right
now is more then you I told you the
other day is more than a use Xbox one
Wow
and that's refurbished that's crazy and
if you look at the 3d s take the 3d
estimate they dropped the price what a
few months in many dr7 it's like you
know like with the Zelda's that they
popped out for the 3ds you know they
popped out the 3d remake of uh of
Majora's Mask and Ocarina time I get
that you know those are 3d that's why
it's on a 3d platform but they could
have ported an HD re-release with like
winwaker Twilight Princess because these
games will help move your consoles
because these are beloved games Nintendo
is the only people the only company in
the gaming industry that can literally
print remake at the same game 15 times
and people will go out and buy it oh
absolutely absolutely but the reason why
the price didn't drop on a dead this
system was because of the architecture
that was inside the IBM PowerPC
flipagram that stuff that's inside there
was too costly on Nintendo and for them
to cut the price any margin any lower
than what it is is absolutely even they
giving them away all right so they're
not gonna do that they'd add they called
them back from the store they recalled
all of them they will rather recall all
of them and sell out the lot yeah well
we'll see I mean at this point right now
like I said the stock is just selling
out I mean they still really moving out
here it would be funny like you said if
they just select so quickly what it
looked like at this rate you know they
can hit that 10 million go you know all
we want is a couple of low features
along the way but we'd be impatient
grandpa exactly
[Music]
shut up a little nu on the chat we're
gonna move on to the next time I'm gonna
get this over them look or King so
Scorpio news no headset it so I was just
about I'm looking at at anything look
official
like acquaint yo for bringing it to the
room tables well he brought it too
little to my attention as well but Lord
King I know this is you right here so
I'm gonna let you rock this little
scorpion
the Scorpion said is a wireless headset
that automatically docks with the system
like once I guess you turn the system on
that automatically pairs with it like a
controller so I guess it takes out the
the cumbersome nature of the controller
being the medium in between the system
and the headset and um the Dolby Atmos
is built-in system at the arm at the
metal level right this is just this is
what I'm understanding hmm right so then
it takes away it just separates the
processing from the UM the CPU and that
dedicated piece of hardware that's in
there that you're going to have the best
sound so my question is for the Scorpio
right being at the headset is Wireless
and are we going to be seeing a wireless
system mm do you think that's a
possibility at this point in time where
we just plug it into a power source and
um we pair it with our television we're
looking for the signal because a lot of
our TVs are smart TVs we have a dongle
that's a HDMI dongle maybe now cuz I
don't think a wireless would be that
strong enough to hold the 4k you're
gonna be we need that native 4k
connection so that's only reason why I
would say no mmm but what if uh what if
they say for 1080p you could do it this
way but if you want to do the 4k you get
a hardwire I just using yeah I think the
hardware it would be too expensive -
you're talking about keep the price down
I don't think they did include something
like that just yet mm-hmm yeah it would
be it would be tough because also I
looks like because looks like they want
to make I guess 4k like such a
requirement from the dev when a base
level you know say that from a
promotional stamp my marketing
standpoint that's what they're really
putting in chest out there for okay we
do this done as far would you say no
wish of thanks no but that's it though
one other to me one of the biggest
mistakes of this generation was when the
Xbox one came out with that chat headset
crap they gotta stay attached to the
damn controller
me again it's one of those things with
Dom a trick the Dom with foolish
decision anyway it's like when it's when
it's not broke don't fix it was one of
those things we had 360s I remember
having that small little wireless
earbuds like at the 4:3 singer wireless
headset it was so smooth I had my
controller I didn't have to stay
tethered to it you know it was just a
beautiful dig it was like when Xbox one
came out I don't know if it was a deal
with Turtle Beach or something they had
but they just forced that damn
connection to the head that did chat
piece and it annoyed me and even like
now I'm like I have the a 50s right the
armed Astros right supposedly wireless
headset right and I still have to stay
attached to her ridiculous so when I saw
this what is it the UH let's get this up
give them some promo here lucid sound
yes
35 X wireless and you know again not
only talking about you know the Dolby
Atmos they talk about Windows sonic like
that's a new feature right now if you
guys in the preview program you know um
it's a feature crack it's kind of like
to simulate almost like a 7.1 surround
bit going on and it sounds pretty good I
actually used a lot of the features and
messed around with the settings on it it
sounds real good they also talked about
like some type of arm but like head
tracking software that's in it so some
type of tech in it too even kind of even
really simulate like almost like a 7.1
and with Atmos and all that so to me I
don't care how much this thing is I'm
going in day one okay
in the 50 but there is you know think
about it think about it is there does
the PlayStation 4 pro have any like
accessories only work with the pearl
like headsets or anything like that no
it wouldn't do that and I would have to
be you're compatible across place to get
a but I think you know this is only for
the score field this won't be able to
work for Xbox one
no I said it does not work so the whole
box
Windows 10 and Xbox Microsoft
peripherals
we're getting it say Xbox he's right yes
Xbox one projects co-op you on Windows
10 alright but it syncs does it syncs
wirelessly
with the Xbox one s like it does I'm
sure they have a confirm that though
they're infirm beautiful ezbee it's a
dog PC in Scorpio
I don't we got a C because it may be an
old-school setup for us because I does
this the the the Xbox even the Xbox one
asks I even have that functionality that
we can go wireless
oh you know I don't think you have
nothing second advantage of it till now
I don't think so on yeah yeah you
probably have to use a dongle the same
with the for the PC you have to use a
dongle
so probably so catchy got you yeah well
I'm sorry let me cut you yeah yeah so uh
Lord adequate really feel about this uh
sack going on just loses interest you
for losing Sam I have to see it check to
check my Twitter feed I actually reached
out my arm have to see it in person all
gases hmm tell me what a little thing if
you seen it at e3 I could tell you that
because if they drop this information
now baby
you guys believe you are covered either
see remember we went to the side and
they had a hole through Microsoft's exit
they was doing the controller's we was
like oh they have a controller lab over
there and they gave us the little cause
of me was able to go in there and make
our controllers at the point in time
well they had a whole series of headsets
there also and it had a whole series of
pcs there because they were um talking
about the play anywhere and the Gears of
War for K and it was giving you the
difference between the 4k and regular
and I'm telling you that setup that they
had Microsoft had in a section was
amazing embracing the PC people while
still keeping the the Xbox people are
enthused and remember PCs are heavy on
the headset so I'm very happy that folks
fences and controller things because he
understands what these guys like and
what we we like and these guys are
having a premium experience and he's
bringing that over to us so I really
appreciate all that stuff oh absolutely
and I guess I can't wait to get my hands
on that so I can mute lord anchorman
that's in the chat
I could do this strong you on my listen
Sam our podcast douches you realize ya
know and we got your Monday edition it
takes great mightiness so we understand
that uh the red skulls down in the chat
room mucking about corporate Louis of I
would get you feel about this are you
are you day one in are you go you
waiting and seeing where you at with
this lucious I never I never like today
one peripherals like that unless less
there's a review of first all a number
of reviews up first so um just look at
the picture of it like build quality
seems like it's pretty good like again
it's something you have to really kind
of get a feel for beforehand so it's a
few people review it and it's positive
yeah more than likely pick it up um cool
coolest you know but you know that it
Astro may well be on the heels of this
and release something else and so I'm
sure turtle beach's is you know doing
the same thing to so this is just the
first one down the pipeline now for this
premium gaming sound what are the law
what are the Lords willing to pay that
200 on table - yeah I think - tree edge
but yeah Tuesday what you say low attic
I say 150 that one zippy
why don't be Atmos all that tech head
track oh you so what he you so what he's
willing to pay okay
what he's what's the price point in this
bad boy let me explain you guys with
static Adsense okay we don't got one
normally I willing to be shout $200 for
a headset because I go through headsets
fast for some reason I don't know why I
take care of my sis at my headsets but
for some reason I have the worst luck
when it comes to headsets yeah you know
brother Holika please
you're not anchor says tree fitty tree
fitty for low-income and he says that no
where you at
with price would you be willing to pay
per would I be I'd be willing to pay a
buck fifty I had believed and I have not
paid no more than 175 for headphones oh
good god she ditches it just like
Wireless does make it convenient you
know that right there huge is one of the
biggest issues I have with um you know
with headsets is shorting like that it
shorts too quickly so if I would be
willing to spend an extra like you know
hundred dollars for something that's
going to be more you know competent
because it's not gonna get a short in it
exactly think think about this look like
a vision three doc said that video three
not as a fifty say he's a fool shut up
Larry Greg you two hundred I see you on
that what's fun doing here you don't
have he's got a thousand dollars doing
that he got that looks like a covers
loss will be doing is thinking in
uncharted but well good sailor attic is
that up with that headset we can
actually have the freedom to move around
to play our switch wireless yeah what I
was confined to my controller I'm not
gonna lie absolutely will you looking up
I'm with you on this headset medicines
it's pretty pretty exciting stuff and I
can't wait for this thing to jump so uh
you know you know what I was thinking
yeah you might really be onto something
with this exit but there switch because
you either get chest Christmas gotta use
another platform he's got he's got four
chapters I think you know those we are
gonna move on and I want to get this
over the Lord smooth because um today we
heard of a big basketball announcement
so we'll talk downstairs for a second
I'll be back no doubt no doubt would eat
law school was was dropping out in these
streets well um we all know our MBA
playgrounds comes out tomorrow for the
switch Xbox one the ps4 it I think PC
maybe but that's not that
that's one news I want to talk about
even though I'm interested maybe a
playground uh NBA 2k 18 pre-order today
and uh they're getting very creative
with their pricing and bundles so you
got it you got a standalone
the standalone game for $59.99 you know
just get the game of course and then you
got the their little special edition at
a hundred dollars and then you got their
legendary edition with all the gold
coins and stuff and a little digital
stuff four hundred and fifty dollars and
I have really a big problem with that
the thing is this is why sports games
should be free-to-play
they should just follow the free-to-play
model they did the thing about 2k and
Madden and all them they dip and dab in
both they do sell you a full retail game
and then still get you with the
free-to-play model and um that's exactly
what this is so that hundred and fifty
dollars let me know on let me look up to
see with with this stuff gets here right
here let me let me open up my Xbox app
right quick because as a digital game
right I still don't know what would
benefit me get in this thing so hey look
Lord snow let me why you look this up
let me read you a comment in the in
except anchorman visas yo I heard LeBron
got removed from NBA Live 18 do you ever
saw coming for you NBA left committee
laughs Wow yeah that would never happen
and I'm alive so it wouldn't bother me
if a certain player was removed because
I'd still you know I stomach I'm nading
anyway so I went with teams like the
Celtics in the Pacers so I got in to
worry but and I got to give it up to
Lord SMO by actually checked out one of
his videos as live streams and when he
plays he plays for real I just really
got good at up oh thanks thanks alright
so let's look at this alright we have
the we have the legend Edition is $49.99
and you'll get Shaq on a cover with a
Lakers Jersey the hundred dollar version
you get Shaq
to cover woody heat Jersey the 59 and
the $59.99 for you you just get NBA 2k
18 logo in the basketball look into what
it's what this stuff is worth right cool
I'm a read this pre-order the NBA 2k 18
legend edition gold now to receive
250,000 virtual currency Shaq digital
items for your my player and more the
NBA 2k seen organizations gold includes
the following digital items 250,000 BC
40 my team packs to build your perfect
fantasy team delivered in one week
featuring a guaranteed shack card one
random team 2k free agent card and more
Shaq attack shoes rookie Shaq Jersey
Shaq official logo t-shirt chat
nicknamed Jersey Shaq championship ring
Mitchell and less Shaq Jersey collection
5 in total additional my player a pair
items 100 is that worth a hundred and
fifty dollars II was told you a Shack
right yes
do they have a weight do you say Jersey
we're not talking about a real Jersey we
talked about him no [ __ ] you're gonna
put on your your rusty player look own I
look number 30 40 I could put it on
right now like it would be yeah you're
stealing my litter in the box
I might have been rich it was a little
mission with Maslow you know the
throwback giant you know you know
probably I have about virtual currency
this VC that today they making bank over
you suffer to follow you from game to
game so you go you can hear you get a
million BC you don't wasted
$250 of real money you get to have BC
and you only got really a year to use
you only can use it on that game
shoutout to Lord that's exactly how life
go not to cut you look exist
they go in every year it's a battle
whenever a new to cake comes out look
look like Lord there they will go and
put down a buck on feces yesterday my
plate could be better than next one
before the game really has we do this
every year I'm like y'all y'all mind
boggling with this ray be like at 2k is
making hand over fist on that VC right
now so I do feel a loss we would say
like like one would think if you put
that much money into the game and it's
tied to your conker they do haven't your
email account Lee you sign in that is
[ __ ] carry off that's crazy began
looking I cut you better that's exactly
how I feel with destiny that's exactly
how I feel my money my time my effort I
tried the other day I tried to do the
ring and it kept saying every time I was
trying my hardest to jump onto the
platform to do whatever it boil down to
the fact that this doesn't matter and I
said damn I said me struggling right
here doesn't matter I was in the room
for the camaraderie with friends but
then the following day I had a chance to
jump in a raid ahead of somebody and it
was like hey you little jumpin and I was
like nope there's not worth effort
because it's not carrying over it's not
even like they're saying they said you
bring your face you get it right you
don't even bring your face like if you
don't bring anything you spend $500
whatever you play how much you spend and
how much time you put into the game and
I see you guys playing on my court stuff
so hard there's no hard man and for it
to be worthless
the next time oh no they got the hustle
going on stop lying
years ago for him to say you got a judge
I know I know they wasn't putting the
real cotton Jersey inside nothing guys
I don't know what crazy right they're
letting children although we have
another NBA game is some time ticking as
of the news no schools were to the table
what do you react feel about those let I
feel Lord smooths pain but I'm gonna
relate it to my sport which is baseball
hello and I spoke a little bit about
this last week MLB the show now let me
let me read something off it and will be
the show Hall of Fame Edition Game Stop
exclusive $20 $100 and you get a box
like a little box with Ken griffeys like
Ken griffeys Jersey name and number kind
of on the box and that's it and then you
get an MLB hat that's not even a fitted
cap like oh no not even that aficionado
fit we get mad not even the most
egregious part of it so I'll be 17 the
show digital deluxe version on PSN one
hundred dollars that's person yeah this
is what you get you get for that diamond
dynasty a car go get a few packs some
gold pack some starter packs mmm you get
a what they call a digital deluxe pack
so the vast majority of stuff you get is
all this time and dynasty stuff that if
you don't like or you don't play it's
it's just noticed it means nothing and
then you get 31 PS for Major League
Baseball themes you can cycle through
all of the ever BT known as the Hustle
is real out here it is a it is
absolutely egregious I don't necessarily
agree that that all games should go into
the free-to-play model but like I said
last week for my m OB since it is the
only game in town I don't like the fact
that they bring out a new game every
year granted they do they have nine
months to turn over a game and the
changes that they make are generally
only
readily apparent to the people that play
those games hardcore that are going to
play 50 games into a season and see the
small nuances and things that have
changed otherwise if you look at it on
the surface you're not really going to
see the differences and not not to catch
because it each at Lord BK bestop I made
a point to your point which was saying
but what do you say to those people I
say you know it's for the enthusiasts if
you had like just heavy into sports then
you know you're gonna buy that there are
no baseball enthusiast that's not the
idiot is for the idiot is not I gotta be
squiddy
no I'm sorry like look I get it I get it
but the thing is if they weren't just
gonna offer them you're nothing but were
your big traded right what's your
favorite play he get traded to that hot
team you don't say or your case related
to baseball with the Yankees they made
that hot acquisition you're saying you
got two three them play you know you're
gonna want to run with that a little bit
no temptation yeah but it is to me again
give me a roster update yeah you know I
mean give me a rock stuff I don't need
any of the other sir give me wrost
update so that your case you will be
content to stay with the base let's say
you know 2016 and as long as they just
keep updating the roster that then you
would be Xillia at least if ideally this
is the way I see it should be done give
me a base game that's a 2017 Emily this
shows 2017 is the base game give me
roster updates when you would normally
release a new game every year for the
next two years roster updates and some
improvements whatever you do don't with
a skeleton team with a skeleton team
take the base team and give me something
brand new a hundred percent polished a
hundred different than what you had
before every two or three years so then
come its refreshed so could they don't
have any competition they don't have any
competition of to me I think you know
I'll never solve the problem
I'm the worst game should only be should
be games for services like this should
there should not be $60 sports games
they shouldn't even release and you lead
it should be literally a massive
mm Oh most people are getting you it
free to play it didn't because I just
don't understand like they sell it right
they they make money off the stuff every
year and didn't even make it even more
money now that they got these ultimate
team cards and now at 2k with ABCs it's
like it works better sauce for schemes
work will work much better as a
free-to-play so here's the issue and I
feel you guys like loss marvelous are
like I'm on the sports guys why I feel
what you got saying the problem is like
I never forget in 2015 I was on at e3
and I had a conversation with Phil and I
said I pull him to the side I was like
fail
what's going on with Microsoft not
having a baseball game like like I was
like really tight I was in my feelings
was my first time you know what he was
like a list of questions I have for but
this is one of them and I'm like so he
looked at me almost perplexed like like
yeah why can't we did he kind of like
leaned over to Angry Bird and you got it
you kind of have to like take
perspective of Phil's picture here you
know he's very sick he's walking on
appointed official they'll be looking
finish it's exactly my point
because we looks over the Greenberg and
Greenberg's looking at him like but you
know that MLB license on which that
cause right like he had that look like
don't be promising the Lord God neither
just yet we had a look at the Dublin's
got a thing
so the vibe I'm getting is that just a
house that licensed that ought to
purchase it so they can have it to be
have the ability to make said sports
games is so costly that they I guess the
way looking at it they just gotta
monetize this thing every year you I'm
saying if you do have the license you
not gonna sit on it because like you
said I mean the nonsense of purpose I'll
be good with the two year old version
just update the rosters or whatever and
then like you know come out with a every
two or three years like a really
revamped robust version at a game but I
think it's just funny I think the
financial doesn't know it absolutely is
financial because if they were selling
PlayStation numbers that they had 60
million consoles in the wild I guarantee
you it'd be it'd be in the conversation
but since they I said since they don't
have it it only makes financial sense
more financial sense for third party to
take on the license and be able to
release on PlayStation on Xbox and on
switch be alone so again that narrows
everything down because again EA hasn't
showed any interest in coming back to
MLB which I don't understand why um
again it looks like a ski that they
jumped out yeah I have to know is this
show like when the show when you have a
premium product that everybody
gravitates to and no matter how many
times you put out a product that could
be equal or greater than but that same
crowd keeps flocking to the one desire
to Idol it disheartens the the Board of
Directors and I don't care how good your
developers are they're not going to get
funded they're going to get pushed to
the side and it's not worth purchasing
this licensee to to rent you know the
licensee and don't make your returns
back off of it I hear what you're saying
the biggest problem is competition
competition push growth if there's no
competition in the marketplace
it's tough but exactly what you're going
to get and this is the problem that you
have so you have to do it with your
dollars you have to grin and bear it
that yet don't buy the game mmm that you
step back from it and hey you can't do
that then don't complain I'm that guy
I'm that guy who used to buy it every
single year and now I'm going on three
years I don't buy the game there we go
I listen I figure shot the lower corner
to chat because um he actually made a
good point as far as like 2k you know
really trying outside even though
there's really no competition for two
cases B I mean obviously live supposed
making a comeback but you know they've
been dominating right so the whole thing
is you know they saying it you know they
try they are trying to make it change it
I remember one you needed to have Spike
Lee even one you know they do try to do
things to try to change it up even
though them online servers that's
something else to be decided you're
talking about that but um you know it is
interesting that um just to see like
from a standpoint what like with low
King is saying from a competition
standpoint like if life could run a low
loss movie rifle up I know you do
yeah I just want them to like get in the
mix in and have a solid addition just to
pull them away cuz I mean we're meal or
king of old heads and we remember the
days of like you know my first NBA 2k I
mean an NFL man what NFL 2k I've known I
was out back and you saw but then they
had it like 20 hours of someone when
years like they were really common there
laughter I believe yeah they were common
at maddens
throw and it was something like okay man
had to get it together and that's the
problem I'm seeing right now like looks
like this single title is kind of
dominating and just doing these small
iterative updates and not really going
in as far as what you know the potential
of the title so I agree with low-key
competition definitely plays a huge huge
part in that yeah I won't buy 2k game oh
I live I'm 30 I listen of course you
vote with your wallet for which a while
I'm all about people voting with their
while and do what they got to do Lord
Lord attitude resident sports guy you
completely out but I figured if they
have what to say or this brother I
figure you on that whole bit but are we
gonna move on a little bit I'm rocking
that so up now about this a Hall of Fame
awards and stuff going on right now some
awards that got dropped Louis off you
got something for the table on this yeah
definitely so this week my topic is
really it's not about any code of drama
or any last minute hot you know hot news
it dropped or anything like that no sort
of technical breakdowns like this week
my topic is basically about you know
warm fuzzy feel good nostalgia like
straight up nostalgia like you know for
me um so last week basically the world
video game Hall of Fame announced its
inductees for this year and I usually
just like our class overworked you know
whatever games are being inducted but
it's never I never really give it much
thought but this year when I looked at
the inductees
I blasted in I said this is kind of a
snapshot of my entire childhood my early
20s and it has three for me anyway three
of the most influential games at
different points of my life um going in
at the same time so it was just cut to
me it was kind of like this rush of like
like kind of like happiness and like
nostalgia that all these games are
coming in at the same time and for so I
just kind of wanted to talk about that
like my personal feelings on some of
these games and I wanted to know what
the lords felt about it
so um so quickly just for me like I
don't have much of a history with
Pokemon so Pokemon Red and Pokemon green
are one of the inductees and I honestly
I was a little too old
when Pokemon came out to kind of had
gravitate towards that but my my brother
Lord kebobs who definitely is a big
Pokemon fan but but for me that the
three other games that resonated started
with Donkey Kong Donkey Kong uh was
released in 1981 for me that was one one
of the first games that I that I got
from my Atari 2600
that along with combat and pac-man were
like the long ones and I had and nano
gtalk cattle G tracks off don't like
vodka bottle and I would play Atari 2600
for hours on end trying to outdo each
other in Donkey Kong and and Donkey Kong
for the 2600 is pretty simple like you
don't have much variety in terms of in
terms of stages it would just get harder
and harder um so this is I mean just
just it just thinking about your
childhood and all the funny hat playing
this game you know without Donkey Kong
we don't have Mario mm-hmm tell me you
think about like odd for me all the
different iterations of Donkey Kong that
I had I mean I had I don't know how many
gaming watches with Donkey Kong
um able talk Donkey Kong like it was
really like everything I could get my
hands on in terms of Donkey Kong I
remember wanting like I didn't have a
colecovision and Lord Cognito knows that
we had a friend named Marcus who had all
of these systems and I go to his house
and I played Donkey Kong on his
ColecoVision
I mean this is to me this this game in a
lot of ways to find my love for
videogames as a young child and I'm just
really happy to see it you'll get it
just do because obviously it's not look
it it it's not considered the
masterpiece that a matter of brothers is
but again without Donkey Kong you don't
have all that other stuff so I was
really happy to see that um the next one
that really that really caught my eye
was Street Fighter 2 this is these are
my teen years these are my teen years
and I was I wasn't around I was away at
school so I wasn't around like Laura
kognito and and Lord uh Lord King to
sort of in play competitively whatnot
but amongst my high school friends like
this was it I mean many a night and the
penny my oh my god on a Super Nintendo
it was the most amazing experience like
we would go hours and hours screaming
yelling I mean the feeling to forget the
feeling that you get when you learn how
to do a dragon punch amazing is amazing
I still remember the feeling I got when
I first was able to throw out a dragon
punch without thinking about it and then
I got to the point like why I mastered
like Zangief spinning pile driver which
is really hard like on the on the Super
Nintendo so stuff like that like I'm
glad to see that this game is getting is
just to because this game is what what
it was the archetype for what fighting
games are today the original Street
Fighter or fighting Street as it was
called on the turbo graphics like it
kind of paved the way for it but it was
still kind of stiff it was very
difficult to control the Street Fighter
II like you were covered or the one you
find a trendy Ryu listen that was
exactly anything is like this was such a
leap from that that it gave you those
controls that you had in games like the
brawlers like like those streets of rage
and stuff like that it gave you that
type of tight control in a fighting game
setting and a one-on-one versus one
setting and it just like
of everywhere like any if it was on
Super Nintendo there was in the arcades
we were playing it like so I'm really
glad for it to finally get us just to
and then finally halo combat Evolved oh
let's talk about it that define my early
20s and I know it did and this is a
shared experience that I had with Lord
King and Lord kognito this this game I
remember what that's my girl laughs
absolutely
I remember standing outside of an EB
Games but Lord King waiting waiting for
the story so I'm gonna pick up our egg
boxes and I already had it in my mind I
only picked up three games on launch get
our launch day I picked up Project
Gotham Racing um
Dead Alive for and halo and I played
them in that order and I did and I
waited to the end of the day to play
Halo I didn't get to halo to about maybe
seven o'clock at night and I was playing
games all day and when I drew halo on I
remember I played for like an hour and I
call Lord Cognito and I said man have
you played halo yeah okay he said no
I've got to oh my lord
call me winning me and it was and this
is just a story the story and the way it
kind of it brought that first person
shooter feel these are fun guys I
personally played half-life on the PC I
played a little bit of counter-strike
and stuff like that
so I had a feeling I had a feeling of
what a first-person shooter should feel
like but it's the first time it was done
properly on a console and that you know
that that feel that AI the way they
reacted to you every move and the story
of Master Chief like it was just an
amazing experience and then when we got
together and we did land parties and we
figured out that multiplayer and did
land parties by that deadly fine leather
coat early 20s like really like the all
of these games are classics in their own
right and and the great thing about it
is that nostalgia
often times it's a little cloudy when
when you go back to these games and not
quite what you remember but what you
have to remember that the nostalgia
comes from place and time
what you know where you are in your life
at that point and that's why those games
are special to you in that moment so I'm
just really it was just really exciting
for me to see all these games coming in
together and be like man that's like a
snapshot of my life like and took my
gaming life so that's real talk man
looks really good if a lot of feels
right now hang right there good feel
good feels right now and I'm noting the
young Jesus listen like Danny oh but I
got something older than that for dead
donkey because I remember pop it in
quarters brother remembers all the
Suzie's saying they're popping in
quarters I picked it up for Atari 2600 I
picked it up for 5,200 and I picked it
up for 7800 a difficult ovation wasn't
as good as the 7800 I had it a tabletop
and I was rocking it very hard when
Street Fighter comes out I could tell
you right now cuz needle knows how we
got down oh I remember when from high
school didn't believe you that you had
the Japanese version Oh matter y'all you
almost got your man killed that day
coming I know God the Lord died that day
Lord was almost down it let me tell you
boy cuz that cartridge cost me $250 and
I brought it with Japanese Famicom
Street Fighter and I've been playing a
lot of Street Fighter busting down mad
quarters probably dropping $20 a day
busing button Street Fighter so mm-hmm
I brought it for I brought a
photographic 16 afford a brother for the
PC engine I brought it for uh the Super
Nintendo and I brought it for the Super
Famicom got it for the Super Famicom
first the ANA brother for Genesis let me
tell you when I first got it Lord
Cognito came over I was working at a
place he brought his friend over and I
looked at the dude the dude had a
ponytail I don't mess with these juices
he's pulling me down man
you know grown-ass man you got a
ponytail look looking with the
straightest [ __ ] as I can ever go sit
there
I taught him don't bring him no no this
look
Galen said it's not arcade perfect I
said good mother
yes get Amada is bad we wasn't try to
hear that when you spread that to an
alley you know what a hitter would talk
about any flaws because you know I know
and I whispered I wish spitting
cognitive ass I can't guarantee your
friends safe passage so get him out of
here
it then came the halo mm
late-loss aqua just explained we were
standing from the EB Games and I
purchased it and I think I got blinks
with it I picked up on whatever the
launch games was I picked up on launch
games and and like he said in that order
those orders that you played the games
and he was like yeah let me check these
games out the first game I put in was
Dead Alive knock that out it was
beautiful breathtaking the next game on
[ __ ] them was well Project Gotham Racing
I was like oh my god it's a maze who
knows number the kudos yes I'm put in
the halo and I remember when it first
hit me when I turned on the flashlight
when the fascial I came on when I win
the dark yes and back then you had to
black in white can oh gee Duke
controller but you know about.i
yeah the big giant joint that could kill
a person let me tell you man when I went
into the dark and the flash light comes
on and what I don't remember flashlights
being done in first-person games up to
that point I'm sorry I don't remember it
but after that I knew that was a thing
that I can't go back up from I can't go
back that's not like they won and I
remember keeping in constant contact
with kognito after you know because we
all did the talk first and then the land
hit when 16 men are up inside a man's
house that with four Xboxes and for
televisions playing Halo 4 10 hour
great there's no more dedication other
than what we was putting in was putting
in their works or anybody talk about
these bars and stripes I wasn't sold in
on our arm so we we purchased TVs to
play together mm-hmm
so everybody's fantastic
Lord Hawk coming up the stairs me his TV
on his back we are all weighed in on we
were all women on putting the money be
able to get the extra t an extra TV
young listen let me let me jump in on
this right quick cuz I know we got some
young bucks on this call I know Lois
move and I know Laura Alex like they
talking some old og talk
let me explain to y'all night Lord
sovereign really just nailed it cuz it's
like I looked at that those inductees on
a Hall of Famers and I was just like wow
like like Lord something just nailed the
perfect light it's like different time
periods that you grew up with you know
I'm saying and you remember so it's like
with Donkey Kong for me is even
especially because my first video game
was from pop do looks like he gave me a
click oh but I say and he just like look
here you go boom got me off on it so I
had the Donkey Kong I remember that all
at Birth marry all that birth to Donkey
Kong Country everything that we got so
now you know saying that it's looking
hot that's the foundation right there
there would be none of this merio
anything without dog because that's what
remember Lord um well King even the
little tabletop joints that that look
like mini arcades it's used to put
remember the small ones that used to buy
angry hey but they were miniatures that
had Donkey Kong so again now people
understand you got a do your history if
you do this video game stuff you got to
do your history so that's number one
number two street fight is so epic like
Street Fighter is so epic people have no
idea like that change the game like just
doing that first all you kid for the
first time and we used to call it the
psychic world kick yeah we just moved up
what'd it sound like because we even
know what it you don't mean what it was
but he was just so amazing and at that
time just the craze that Street Fighter
had like it just it just tore the roof
off man and even before that one with
the stuff the original part one and I
remember Lord King you had that turbo
graphic CD fitted net and that actually
was arcade perfect you know it was a
huge heart it was the it was the first
time a human car and I think it's the
extension to put it in well let me tell
you like that that was when I was like
wow like back cuz back in those days
laureles movers like arcade games came
out now there was a look there was a
little drop-off when you got the console
version that was just a fact that we
started to notice it okay exactly I look
or this is not exactly has but it was it
was like as the evolution got more and
more starting starting to get closer on
your closer and then we start bringing
to halo I mean listen like the way
the way I look at halo was like I guess
how these young kids look at Call of
Duty now you know I mean like halo was
the og like that was that changed the
game of FPS like there was no FPS that
control the way control the smoothness
in the graphics that the story the a I
did the AI not following set patterns
and doing all that stuff and I just
remember remember the grunts like we
just pop went ahead and a little
birthday a like I just remember that
game and then I'm just talk about the
single play then when we found out we
said alright let's touch them all to
play let's see what's about it shout out
lo ha no we had a well what's the
projects of the night like hey your home
project code my house for TVs Melrose je
m'appelle did like everybody it was all
about Haley yeah you don't say was every
Saturday be at law Carlito's crib we got
the Halo going on we're gonna talk that
talk we gonna go in everybody's doing
team deathmatch then like did they have
I'm trying to think back then do they
have the other modes to date it was a
death mansion on that the big battle one
right all better
I capture the flag pig bridles oh man
the rival reason how beasty that the
regular pistol used to be the regular
pistol Opie listen got off the hog shut
up yo shout-out to mooncake that start
just putting it down talking about
penguin village New York City child
channel fair this is real OG talk I'm
feeling right now I know we're you guys
right that's where we got it from the
understand outlaw sinister tuna chat he
was a beast just to watch him ha lord
King all y'all going at it on that hallo
yo Lord Jason Lord David remember they
took nowhere halo movement and took it
to the corners on the streets three TVs
in front of the coochie free Thunder
stay like halo was a movement that
changed console FPS there was nothing
like it and then that evolved into what
we now know halo 2 and when halo 2 job
it was okay that's when Xbox Lazo it was
over it was over so now you're saying
that we could do that tradition that we
did in other people in our own homes
like it was mind-boggling at that time
Lord I'm finally learning like Xbox Live
for what it did and that whole
foundation so again just seeing this
list it's just a whole nostalgic just
like a whole rush eat I'm saying and
it's just that's history right there but
I'm curious to see what the young oh
jeez feel about this list so know we're
ever going back in the day talk about
them old mixtapes law school which which
you feel on this man when you see this
this less he taxing he had something he
had a handle Oh yet or no that so i'ma
give it to you attic what do you feel
when you saw this list just can someone
give me the list please but it mr.
Street Fighter 2 Donkey Kong halo 1 I
believe what the pokemons on the list
also already know bad games I feel like
just because a game is for now
extremely good doesn't necessarily mean
it should be like Hall of Fame worthy I
feel like a Hall of Fame game should be
something that revolutionized gaming in
general talk about it like a halo made
first person shooters mainstream on
consoles mmm it made it made sure it
didn't make it mainstream that made it
socially acceptable to gamers to play on
consoles because before that it wasn't
it was a PC thing absolutely Call of
Duty made it mainstream on consoles
because it made it to where it was like
you know that they made the term Dubrow
everywhere you're like you know just
because people call a game Dubrow that
doesn't necessarily make it a bad thing
it's just the cat it's a huge casual
market game you know uh I would say that
you know Street Fighter is it did
deserves me on there because it kept the
fighting genre to its peak you know it
without Street Fighter it's debatable of
some of these head-to-head fighters and
be existing absolutely because of that
game you know I feel like games that
revolutionize gaming they deserve beyond
uh you know Pokemon Pokemon I feel like
the reason it's on there it's one of the
few exceptions Pokemon took on a mine of
its own like especially when I was
growing up you know I was invited about
Weddington perspective on poke and I
really was curious about your
perspective on talk about when I was you
know you see games a car I mean poco if
you can't if you get so big where you
can just flop out a half-ass card game
because of your name that's when you
know you've made it yo and to this day
people still play the Pokemon game you
know there's a reason it's a
billion-dollar franchise because no one
had that that turn base you know in
Nintendo did that that's one of the main
reasons that the the handheld market is
dominated by Nintendo is because of
Pokemon people don't necessarily only
play pokemon on the handheld's but they
buy a to play pokemon and they get all
the other software afterwards mm-hmm you
know I would honestly say the most
innovative company that's in gaming is
Cinda because they have so many
franchises you know without Mari we
wouldn't have these three platformers we
would without Pokemon you know so you
know I think Final Fantasy seven would
be in the Hall of Fame thing because
that really opened people's eyes to the
Japanese market in the western coast
because people didn't really attach to
Japanese market in the western coast
until that game you know people bought
it but people would abide in the in the
horrors that they did after that shut
out the look of a jamais like told you
but hey teaches died and kids game boys
in it wait for them take it away put it
for me students that's how addictive
that game was that's good do their I
think there's I feel like there should
be more games on that Hall of Fame and
then that there actually is you know uh
I think that you know again that's
probably going to be recognized and
probably go in the Hall of Fame in a
color like in five to ten years is the
Witcher I think The Witcher is really
put like a milestone to like this is
where your RPG is now this is where you
got any now so you know there's games is
costly doing that it's like a you know
we are talking a couple weeks ago if
crackdown is anything what they claim
it's going to be you know that's going
to be another milestone that's like this
is what action-adventure games are this
is what you gotta be it's like I
consider a game that's Hall of Fame
worthy is something that changed the
entire gaming industry to be more like
that game absolutely absolutely i 100%
it has to be revolutionary has to change
the game is that it has to introduce a
mechanic or something that's never been
seen before and then generally when you
see that type of thing you see other
games tempted to follow suit and then
you come up you know sometimes those
expression oh this is a halo clone or
this is a you know poke mark like that's
when you know that the base game set the
trend you know I mean a central movement
kind of looking I know you gotta get out
of here but before I don't watch want to
get a little low oh gee top for your
left
this ain't what I feel my fee
well I'm back I'm hurtin so that's
smooth is done I believe um I've got got
a so gtalk I think he was like yeah it's
time to take that trash out like a van
as like he's always sleep I slept since
yesterday it's all good we did that with
a few very fella that's the lack of
respect for the whole Jase whatever
stays on your neck exactly good without
you guys
contributing to the gaming industry in
its early days we wouldn't be where we
are now man that's our buddy back in the
day would be where it is now and I was
consuming my money had a lot of money
but especially my money bottom $250
cartridges for that Oh Lord oh Lord
yeah people broke out them streets I had
to get a job working for the think I
need oh and I usually get kicked out of
the Wiz all the time for playing based
on mr. congressman go to play and play
baseball stars Wow clicking bet yeah
that is this is this is definitely still
charges and this is like also like the
you see now that the death of the
mom-and-pop because like you know for
them game where I know BK bit best on
the chat imagine some Brooklyn spots
Chinatown like the thing about low attic
which is so differently you know the
without the prominence of gang stop and
all that stuff at the town you still had
like little subsidiaries like fun :
EB game and stuff like that okay get it
those eventually became game stock that
was brought out but um it is funny
because you had the competition of going
to like a little mom-and-pop joint and
getting these games ahead of time and
then get oh yeah yeah the gig again yes
some negotiating options like you
weren't forced to just go to one
Clay's like you do the I were but up the
block they got a 55 that stream [ __ ] you
don't say like you can't talk your way
into situations like gaming was
differently but you know it's like you
go to gazed up you know it only ones in
town that's it you at their mercy
you know it's kind of thing you know
besides best buy maybe that will revisit
that conversation in five years
terrific if they even exist if not more
than five but they are definitely on
their deathbed big solid jump before we
wrap this traffic up this is a good one
oh man I guess I'm just glad that you
know got to talk to the young books
about this stuff because it is important
you know any to remember these things
because you know as we sit here and
complain about you know servers not
working and you know this this
resolution does danielle de you is
always important remember where you came
from because it's like again and it's
like a lord addict said like if we
hadn't been the hardcore gamers that we
were back then and still continue to be
gaming wouldn't be where it is it just
wouldn't absolutely it needs as
important and it needs a continued
support so yes it brings it back to my
same comments earlier when the young
buck was talking but I need my denim
functionality I must switch the word I'm
like the compound bruh you gonna get a
Christmas present voice-chat baby but
this is another on in the books it's
gonna wrap this thing up was good to be
back talking with the Lords at the
roundtable shout out the lost [ __ ] off
you still around butterfat for jumping
in an elastic fight really bad on
Twitter right now you've got to do what
he's got to do that he's got his
responsibilities but I appreciate what
him and Webb well what they doing and
also that a crushing challenge he's got
popping off with uncharted like tuned in
the data I was pretty funny
watching him battle too and hopefully
Caen yes that I was talking to Lord
cogito I was like yo I was like well you
want to play some Mario Kart
like I know this is gonna sell we but I
watch it smoothly I just are you going
to eat not looking you gotta watch it
cuz it almost reminds me and look I
boxed also know it almost reminds me of
the battles that you guys used to have
with law ha about who's gonna beat
better than even one super you lift it
go Oh watching watch your mess up on
this part right here oh it's rap like
it's literally nice to do these kids to
do it you know there it just sort of
twitch they do a little big stage like
we probably and all that is talking
impel piece better you know yeah yeah I
did the most creepiest thing to be ever
he trolled me he told me over the phone
he called me and said where you at in
Tomb Raider I said I just made it to
this tune he saw for real oh okay did
you go around here I said nah I said
that he saw he the laughs oh hey I want
to run a corner and I didn't get
whatever he was looking for he was like
you did I said I did it he said wait a
second you went around all the way over
there yeah so you'll do it again
I want to run a corner pull my job I was
bad okay he get away as dish out of me
so he tells me he's like yeah I did that
to him I did that I'm like he telling me
about that experience
nope yeah you know I'll never forget man
is playing destiny and playing a Oryx is
ready it when it come to the lever room
with the you know the levers that push
out we always made the newbie go first
if he just got slugged out to the wall
played with someone new I think the only
person that was like this those smell
right was John he was like I feel like
I'm getting set up for something like
that man
hey you first you just want to see if
you could actually
get through it he he's like okay then he
got hit he's like you know what forget
you got this egg I mean this moments
like that okay we got like a zillion of
these moments Justin in gaming and we
talked all day and just all man just the
memories but it's good to see the games
that we grew up with just get recognized
and get the shine and deserve like law
sovereign was saying because this
Disney's built the foundation for what's
today you know so do your history young
oh geez out there do your homework check
these joints tile cool we all go wrap
this thing up I want to get our outros
poppin Lord saw making the people not
found you cuz you promised me get that
count these wedding cameras I was gonna
go public right now anyways you cannot
find me on xbox live at being sovereign
and on PSN ever examine one word and and
you follow him rightly with you be
seeing but Lord sovereign on Twitter and
hopefully my next I by next podcast guys
will have that info Lord kibosh will be
very pleased
those doubted of course I want to give
off to my brothers from another mother
Lord addict what's going on with Danny's
gaming streets what's going on you guys
um pretty sure tomorrow I'm gonna have
an attic show on e3 press conference
predictions uh I do have some plans that
are kind I'm going to talk to the you
know the other iron Lords podcast
probably after this podcast about you
know our next couple shows so stay tuned
on Twitter for that you know definitely
follow us on everyone except for Lord
sovereign obviously I don't know
everyone thought everyone's Twitter
links you know YouTube definitely
subscribe you know today was on Monday
because we had certain things but we
normally stream Sundays at 1:00 p.m.
we've been pretty consistent with that
here lately so I definitely do that uh
and you know stay tuned because I think
specially live right get lish
out two loads on that and of course I
gotta get the out you're going to
premium game himself the og beloved Lord
King where can people find you so find
my Instagram Twitter Facebook
PlayStation Network and Xbox Live Xbox
Live King David OTW the real King David
on Twitter Instagram the real King David
and on PlayStation Network Xbox 360 love
oh my god you know hey we still got the
best podcast you doesn't never heard man
we appreciate this but you'll make sure
you hit that like button for real like
that like button subscribe spread the
word we out here we have a lot of stuff
popping see loraq he's got some stuff
going to also III is gonna be really
let's shout out the playback gaming
network dizzy and those guys after hours
podcast doing it right now I gotta get I
gotta get my behind over there get some
drinks with those guys it's really cool
really fun laid-back you better stay
away from the favorite conversation he
was having last yeah says some trifling
stuff and a shout out the offices faces
reefer - he says it's a flea busy stuff
but we love what they doing over there
and um yeah man we appreciate the
support like I said like subscribe to
find us on iTunes and SoundCloud
youtubes please hit that like button
share it let's get this thing moving and
on that note ER out peace